Yeah.
When I graduated from Trinity College in
Law,
I was fortunate enough to go to the
Harvard law school at a particularly
interesting time.
I'm the class of 68 so I was there in
1967 and 68 and that was a time when
young Americans are questioning the war
in Vietnam.
They were interested in civil rights
programs in the south than Martin Luther
King was assassinated.
That here and Robert Kennedy just after
I graduated and I came back to Ireland,
imbued with that sense that young people
can make a difference.
And I was elected to the Irish Senate
very shortly afterwards and the first
measure bill in the parliament that I
introduced to the age of 25 was a bill
to legalize family planning.
It seemed to me to be very simple
because married women were not allowed
to have the contraceptive pill unless
they had cycle regulation problems and
it must have been the weather.
But there was a phenomenon of many
married women having cycle regulation
problems and also you couldn't
buy or sell the pill.
It was a criminal offense.
But if you could manage to get a pill,
oh,
sorry,
the condom,
and you could use a condom,
but not by herself.
And I felt this is something that just
needs to be straightened out.
And I completely underestimated the
grave offense and a concern that I
caused to a whole range of people.
I was denounced by bishops and priests
from the pulpit,
and I was denounced by newspapers.
I was an outcast for awhile,
and it was a very troubling experience.
I kind of wobbled because I'd been used
to being more or less reasonably admired
and liked.
I was doing well,
and suddenly I was actually a heat
figure and got hate mail.
It was very good for me because I
learned a lesson,
but a few really believe that something
is important and it's true.
Then stick to it.
Go through with a,
pay the price,
be unpopular.
Don't be arrogant,
but sometimes you have to stick to your
principles.